so listen whether you're an introvert or
an extrovert the introverts are kind of
like I don't know if I want to create
content I'm kind of like the private guy
to myself I kind of watch everybody I'm
more observant I don't want to really
put my life out there you're the
extrovert you like to put your life out
there you post pictures of you without a
shirt on drinking party and you're in
Rosarito Miami you're so comfortable in
your own skin but the types of content
you create isn't necessarily helping you
advance on life whatever it may be today
I'm gonna break content down in a way
maybe you haven't heard before one why
you ought to create content to the types
of content to create the audience the
platform and last but not least 10 rules
for creating content so by the way
before the video ends I'm going to make
another recommendation on a video to
watch that has to do with everything I'm
talking about today but let me get right
into a number one why create content one
of these is probably going to describe
you let's go through the first thing is
influence you want more influence you
want influence amongst your family
amongst your community amongst your
people you do business with your peers
it doesn't matter you're looking to have
more influence number two SEO purposes
let me explain what I mean by this
before I started creating content on by
attainment I used to just create content
on our company's website to give it
better SEO because an article would be
shared then they would go on the
company's website I would say oh my gosh
this is an interesting company what do
you do then I'd get a lead and somebody
would contact me about wanting to do
business with them that's another reason
to create content or it's personal you
have a website you create content it
gets shared people say wow who is this
guy who is this gal I want to get to
know more than they go to the about you
section they read up on you then they
follow you on twitter follow you on
Instagram see the pictures you post they
send your message and someone came again
on a call together that happens all the
time
number three targeting keywords you have
certain set of keywords that have to do
with your business on a daily basis real
estate finance pharmaceutical doctor
soccer mom parenting whatever it is
that's the keywords you're specifically
looking for you want to target that
number for positioning you want to be
seen as an expert in your industry so
they see the content by you this guy may
be an expert you want to have influence
you want to have a voice you won't have
credibility your purpose to create
content may be purely position
within your own industry five fame maybe
you want to be famous maybe for you it's
like look honestly I'll just be honest
with you I want to walk through the
streets and I want people to know who I
am cool at least you're being honest
about it you want fame that's another
reason number six money you kind of want
to create content have some influence
where all of us on you're getting
sponsorships you know we got a call from
Amazon Amazon wants to do sponsorship
would value 10 we may or may not be
interested in the sponsorship but they
contacted us this happens all the time
this may be your route that you want to
go yourself next one seven selfish fun
prank for you it's like I just want to
have fun so I want to create content I
want you to see the fun side of me this
is who I am and I don't care whether you
like it or not this is kind of what I
want to do I like creating content I'm
having fun creating content honestly
it's brought me and my sister closer
it's brought me and my husband closer
it's brought me and my friends closer I
kind of like what I'm doing and whether
you like it or not I really don't care
this is really Who I am I'm 17 years old
I want to draw this and this is what we
talk about no problem that's another one
next one could be legacy you're
documenting your content because one day
you wish your parents recorded you when
you were four years old and there's no
content of you when you were four years
old and you creating content so one day
when you're not around your kids your
grandkids can sit there and say that's
the grandpa that's my grandma what was
she thinking about at this time what was
he thinking about at this time how old
was grandpa here
how old was grandma here when she wrote
this I wonder let me see wow she was 32
years old what was she going through was
mom born yet that's thick by the way
we're not even experiencing that yet
we're not gonna explain this for another
20 30 40 years until people start dying
off and we're reading the content that
is so still early on that part of legacy
and documenting necks it could be impact
you want to make an impact around the
world next one is therapy let me explain
what I mean by therapy there are people
that after creating content and they say
I'm a veteran I was in the military I
got out I'm not gonna lie to you and
tell you everything was good I was going
through PTSD because I went to
Afghanistan and I saw people dying my
friend died in my arms this was very
difficult for me I started drinking and
I'm just sharing with you my pain and
this is therapeutic to me and then all
of a sudden 80 other veterans say I feel
you me too then there's a community and
that works for that
community that could be the case for you
next one could be internal let me
explain to what I mean by internal we
use this a lot
internal could be you're creating
content you had a family reunion okay
you put the video together you create a
channel for the Johnson reunion and that
channel creates content that's only for
the Johnson family and all the videos
are unlisted it's only for the family to
watch and you share with the family or
you're running a business you're running
an office and you have you know people
that are other offices and you're trying
to get a message to your technology or
engineers and you say okay this is
what's on my mind right now pop up up
about here's what I like to see
everybody doing the company and this
goes to your 10 you know independent
folks that are working for your
freelancers that's working for you
that's a complete different reason to
create content that helps you increase
the value of company your family your
relationship your friends you're doing a
fantasy football so you have an internal
channel for your 20 friends that are
doing fantasy football you create
content John I want to kick your ass
I want to do this that's still creating
content now one of these you connect
with if you're connecting you would
wanted them your next question is going
to be ok now what do I do now let's talk
about the types of content for you to
create here it is trending news what
happened today Trump business sports
trending something that just took place
today too business money politics
education philosophy entertain comedy
humor technology product review let me
do a review on this new product there
are people that do product reviews that
are doing Lego reviews you know how I
know that my kids watch those reviews on
toys and they put them together right
there's so many different things with
product review
vlog family how-to those are some of the
types of content that you can create now
a tap remember this acronym tap type
audience platform a who's your audience
niche industry it's only real estate its
financial its sports it's such and such
it's a niche right who you're going to
age I'm looking for 16 year olds 25 year
olds 40 year olds married with kids
fifty five year olds getting closer to
retirement whatever it is age
demographic certain demographic you're
looking for women men
single married divorced widowed a wife
of a veteran who's serving in a military
and she's by herself for 18 months while
he's on whatever it is it's a specific
targeted demographic that you want to
touch next views maybe they share the
same views as you politically
spiritually philosophically that's the
interest that they may have a similar to
I watch an MBA Stephen a Smith says
something I respond to Stephen a Stephen
a Smith is wrong he has no clue what
he's talking about maybe it's hip-hop
maybe it's a music world or certain area
that you're talking to that's interest
area country I'm mainly targeting London
UK
but for me it's San Francisco I'm at at
a Houston area so h-town right I'm gonna
go to specific areas that you're going
for right and last but not least
language you're doing these videos on
Spanish right now there's a channel
called value taming Russia it's videos
that is specifically for Russia they
take our videos on what I'm doing and a
translator translates the whole thing if
you were to go watch my interview with
Michael Francis you're on the channel in
Russian it's an hour and seven minutes
all in Russian going back and forth but
it's a language and they decided to
focus on Russia I think about a team in
Russia channel has like 40,000
subscribers as of today so what is that
language you want to focus on so type
audience platform let's talk about
platform you got to realize that for
everybody watching this okay I connect
with a girl who is a professional
bodybuilder she's got a 8 pack it
doesn't even make any sense what she
looks like when I go through my physical
she takes my blood and it's all these
you know people that are there and
they're all you know Fitness and shape
all these things I look at her her
content is purely about Fitness is what
she's doing here's a point if you got a
face and you look incredibly good you
got to use it okay if you got a voice
and you're a good communicator you got
to use it if you got a body and you look
good maybe you use that because it's for
fitness right if you're a great writer
you're very good you gotta use it if
you're good in front of the camera you
got to use it but you got to know which
one works for you right now watch this
name face body one of those three works
for you you've got our last name your
last name everybody knows use it so now
platforms written write a blog LinkedIn
or another blog there's so many blogs
for you to use pick insta so you want to
put a picture and you write something on
the instant on Instagram out of your
podcast there's so many places right now
to use for podcasts and your speaking
your thoughts any of these things you're
talking about write podcasts by the way
many of you don't know that value
tainment is on iTunes just go to iTunes
type in value taming all our stuff I
think like two hundred and twelve
episodes as of today are on podcast so
some of your driving you want to listen
to it in your car click on a value Timmy
channel you can subscribe post some
comments there your reviews there and
actually listen to the stuff while
you're working we have a podcast as well
video youtube facebook facebook wants to
compete with youtube so that's lengthen
instagram a snapchat twitch for some
people that are gamers that's a complete
different world that's niche as well by
the way gamer here the gamer world is
twitch bothell we have a twitch channel
every once in a while i get on there i
play backgammon the other day on with
victor ashkenazi you would have watched
me play the game with backgammon with
victor Ashkenazi you would watch a live
on Twitch you can follow us on Twitter
attainment that's where gamers are guys
sometimes here at the home office at the
studio they play FIFA the new FIFA and
you're sitting them listening to them
talk smack that's a complete way to
create content so now we've covered why
to create content type audience platform
now let's talk about rules okay
and by the way my rules are my rules it
doesn't mean they're your rules I could
be wrong there's a lot of people that
are disagree with my rules but these are
my rules and these are some things I
want you to be thinking about number one
more content doesn't equal more
influence let me say it again more
content doesn't necessarily equal more
influence some people just want to put
so much content out there we were coming
up and we were studying other channels
and I thought this was the philosophy
and one other channels had 4,000 videos
on their YouTube channel in the business
world one of the biggest names and it's
a content creator it's a brand it's not
even an individual it's a company and it
had been creating content since YouTube
first got started I said why did he only
have to 300,000 subscribers they got
4,000 videos then I want to watch the
videos and I looked at it 228 views
193 views 673 views 498 views their last
50 videos one of the videos at 10,000
views and then I went to the beginning
and I saw they had three videos that had
a couple million views so those few
videos that got a couple million views
that they posted five years ago is the
reason why they have this many
subscribers not because of what they're
doing today so this whole strategy of
let me just throw stuff up on the wall
you can be doing that look I every
single time we take more time to create
content it always shows on the numbers
and the results every single time if we
take more time to create content it
always shows on the results every single
time just look at the different
personalities on YouTube who get
interviewed by different people and look
at the viewership and the commentary
below read the comments below and you'll
be able to say this person interviews
deeper this person same subject rules
for money this person same subject
you know mistakes I met as an
entrepreneur this person same subject
but their views are higher why is it
deeper what's going on here that's
different
or is it just let me share with you how
to go become a millionaire because guess
what the word millionaire does very well
when I put it on a title you've got to
get deeper with the content you're
creating so right there number two
control the narrative if you don't talk
about what you believe in what your
views are who you are as an individual
the world is gonna control who you are
because they'll tell everybody who you
are one of the biggest benefits to that
was watching an interview the other day
on when they asked LeBron about him
missing free throws because LeBron been
missing a lot of free throws and Stephen
Highsmith came and said LeBron is a
courier 73% free-throw shooter right but
50% free-throw shooter last five minutes
of the game and when it comes down to
the deciding game free throws he's like
40% and he says LeBrons never been a big
free-throw shooter then his partner
comes out and says in today's social
media world you can hide you could in
the eighties you can today so when they
asked LeBron what do you think about
your free throw shooting he says it's
horrible I gotta get back in practice I
have to get back and get at these free
throws cuz I'm not good at it today
thirty years ago he could get away with
that today he has to explain it
the
because we're living in a world that if
you don't control the narrative and talk
about the things you're dealing with
somebody else is gonna control the
narrative and talk about what you're
dealing with so you got to share your
views on what your think about one of
the reasons why you ought to create
content number three find your one word
that works for you and the words that
don't work for you let me explain get a
sheet of paper ask people who know you
very well
boyfriend/girlfriend husband/wife mom
dad brother sister anyone that knows you
very very well your best friend who you
hang out with knows you very well who's
not afraid of telling you the truth and
you ask him when you think about me what
word comes to mind what do you mean what
do I know a lot about what am i
passionate about movies business money
finance skateboarding sports tell me
what it is that what can I go really
deep an NSC a trend and and see if that
word matches your passion as well if the
word matches your passion you go for it
for us the one word was entrepreneur
very simple we went after that word and
we became who we are today on value
tainment you go on YouTube you tap an
award entrepreneur you'll see value Tim
and all over the place why because we
wanted that as our wort and we learned
what will believe it or not we have a
list just two days ago I sell with these
guys and I'm saying listen since I look
at this word here said this word on
titles has never served us we have a
handful of words that have never served
us when we create content the excitement
the enthusiasm the enthusiasm from the
audience it's never worked why you have
to know those words we know both words
on what works and what doesn't work
number four collaborate accordingly
sometimes we get people that say things
like well why don't you collaborate with
this guy and why don't you collaborate
with this guy a lot of people we've
spoken to just so you know this so it's
not like we're you know are not reaching
out or not having conversations some of
the ones we talk to and it's just maybe
it's not the time right now to
collaborate together maybe let's try to
work on a bigger project together so
when and does happen it's bigger there
are some people that I listen and i
tunnel that's value Tim and we get along
no problem and there are some people say
I just don't know if we have similar
philosophies and beliefs point if you
get too early and you start
collaborating with anybody and everybody
and you're part of a clique you're
officially part of that clique everybody
sees you as being part of that clique
you have to know exactly what community
you're OK
being labeled with because once you
collaborate that's what happens right
but once you realize you know I've
tested I've done some other stuff here I
kind of feel like this is the direction
we're gonna be going to and this is who
we want to collaborate with stay true
that and that leads me to the next point
do not prostitute your brand a lot of
people prostitute their brand you know
we got so many offers from people that
said we'll pay you $100,000 we want you
to say this we'll pay $200,000 we want
you to say this and we always said no
because it just didn't make sense we get
numbers of offers of people wanting to
do stuff on value tainment that
sponsorship that we say no to because it
doesn't match what we stand for and so
we stay true to the audience because the
audience comes and says if we ever do
any kind of sponsorships you'll know I
support what that brand is I'm gonna say
I support this brand here's what I think
we ought to do with this brand and
you'll say wow that's actually
sponsoring somebody right now because we
use that product or we believe in our
product don't prostitute your brand your
followers will appreciate you if you
don't process your brand number six
study your data and test actually look
at the numbers how many minutes do
people stay on with you when you're
writing an article how many views they
got how many people stayed on did they
get off you know that they comment did
they not comment what's going on good on
what time what time when you posted this
time works for you maybe nine o'clock
isn't a good time because we're Eastern
Central Pacific you gotta look at all
that stuff with your data when you look
at the data and you say wow this is
actually good for us to start posting
you like this and I like this by the way
when we first started it was about
creating one content per month that's
what I committed to one blog I wrote per
month then I went to writing once a week
it was on a Sunday night that's how we
started and then it was one video a week
for a year and a half was one video week
then two videos a week and then we got
specific but we test a lot on so we got
to where we're at today next show your
mistakes and be vulnerable my gosh I
cannot tell you how many mistakes we
made one of the favorite videos of ie10
is the video I made 12 mistakes I made
as an entrepreneur if you haven't
watched it I think it's like a blue
thumbnail you can go watch it it talks
about the mistakes I made if you only
talk about everything you do right it's
a turn-off you got to talk about a lot
of the mistakes you made because there's
there's no way in the world anybody
makes it to the top of their game or
does good at anything without having
made
a lot of mistakes people believe it or
not want to know more about the things
you did wrong and the things you did
right believe it or not people want to
hear your mistakes more than the things
you did right next focus and stay
consistent if you say once a month
commit to once a month and stay focused
if you say once a week do it once a week
can you imagine if the news was supposed
to report every night at 8 o'clock one
day they say oh we were late today 9:30
now we're not gonna do it today we're
gonna go tomorrow you know it's okay
they can't do that because then you
wouldn't take him seriously your
audience wants to see you trend with you
the more focused you aren't consistently
they know every Monday more like this
last week we were late on motive and a
motivational Monday by four hours you
know how many messages we got if there's
anything I can't stand when we do is
when we're late on an episode why did we
go late it was an issue that I made a
decision to go late on a video that we
already had prepared it was already
editing it wasn't a mistake on our team
myself I woke up at 5 o'clock I said
this video is not going alive I came
back I told the guys we're reshooting I
shot a video early in the morning after
I did my cardio and then we put it up
for hours that I said I'm we're late but
this the video going out but you gotta
know that your audience how many people
told us bad you guys are late where's it
at where's it at where's it at and then
we went live with and we apologize for
being late with the number 9 challenge
them to question your views for instance
here's what I think LeBron should be
doing do you agree with me do not agree
me tell me your thoughts here's what I
think needs to happen with business what
do you think about it put your thoughts
below here's what I think I need to be
doing with this ask for people's
thoughts whether they agree with your
views or not because you're gonna find
some stuff that's gonna help you out as
well especially as you're coming up
first and you're not an influencer yet
and you want to get a lot of dialogue
that is a good way to get participation
and last but not least content you
create that's for today versus evergreen
meaning if I talk about stuff that's
relative only for today's news it's only
for today's news you ain't gonna watch
it two years from now but if it's
content I create that is evergreen it's
gonna last a long time what is the
pro/con of both here's all it is if you
create a content that has to do about
today it immediately gets a lot of hits
immediately but it only lasts for one
day or two days okay so it goes like
this bow
and in its flatline okay that's still a
benefit because people want to know your
views but if you create an evergreen
content they may go like this but it'll
last forever five ten twenty years from
now they're still gonna be watching it
think about how to win friends and
influence people the book that was
written many many years ago eighty nine
years later people are still reading
that book because it's evergreen a
thousand years from that people gonna
want to learn how to win friends and
influence people so evergreen versus
trendy today you can pick and choose
which way you want to go those are some
of the rules when it comes onto creating
content and if you haven't watched a
video like I promised you twenty four
keys to making you content go viral a
lot of people asked us we had a video
that went viral and got 31 million views
how did you do it I made a video and I
give 24 points how to make your content
go viral it's very specific click on
this link if you haven't seen it and by
the way anything question starts yet
about today's video send me a tweet at
Patrick mid David and I will respond
back to you thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye